make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
any of you guys remember when jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers
first launched and we got to the story i
remember which one it was i want to say
it was the last white event but we get
to the story arc where where like black
swan
talks about like the library of worlds
and how it was a gift from the ivory
kings and like nobody knew who the ivory
kings were and didn't find out until the
end of the story but i remember seeing
like all these fan theories
about the ivory kings right people were
like who in the heck are the ivory kings
some people thought it was existing
characters some people thought it was
new characters it was amazing turned out
to be the beyonders but like it was
amazing you know we never really did
finish remastering jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers did we i know
we did infinity
during the time that infinity war and
avengers in game was coming out but we
never remastered the rest of it let me
know if you guys want to see that right
because like
it's like i'm re-reading it again right
now it's still the greatest
avengers and new avengers story ever
told in reality it's a black panther
story
right it's like the best black panther
story ever told ah but in this video
we're covering two powerful for the mcu
the beyonders now here's a crazy thing
about the beyonders any of you guys who
read or who saw my videos or read the
story's secret wars
you had the beyonder and then in secret
wars 2 you had the same character the
beyonder who visits earth this is where
everybody gets confused
because everybody looks at the concept
of the beyonder and then they ask the
question
how does it relate to the beyonders and
in marvel comics like the beyonders
existed have existed for a long time but
you never really saw them you didn't
know what they looked like
the only real indication we got was the
form that the beyonder took during
secret wars 2. but jonathan hickman kind
of cleaned all this up during avengers
and new avengers and what he did is
is is where he hearkened back to like
old stories right so like the unofficial
basically secret wars three from like
you know fantastic four
issue number whatever it was three
fourteen or something like that one
rough top my head well they basically
talked about the idea of the beyonders
some beings that existed from like the
beyond verse right
the space beyond the multiverse and the
marvel comics what what hickman
basically said
is that the beyonder that we saw in
secret wars and secret wars 2
was basically the equivalent to a child
right that's really all it was um
whereas the beyonders are like
the adults and you kind of have to
believe that like it's it's like it's
like what is it uh it's like jaws three
right like it's a little kid's shark you
know and it's like oh my god you know
there's a shark in the in the lagoon you
know and they're like oh man you know
it's crazy and people are panicking and
they catch it and they kill it and it's
like okay cool everything's safe and
then like the blonde chick comes running
in she's like she's like it is this
isn't the one that killed over men right
like it was its
mother did and then this and then like
louis gossett jr is like the damn
shark's mother you know and it's like
all that kind of crazy stuff and then
like there's this 35 foot long great
white shark that just comes
swimming up to the window and it's like
the most ridiculous looking thing ever
ah but that's that's what this is right
as powerful as the beyonder was in
secret wars 1 secret wars 2 and we're
talking about a character that was so
powerful that the only being that could
really go toe-to-toe against it was the
molecule man owen reese the beyonders
are even further above that and that's
what makes them too powerful for the
marvel cinematic universe understand
guys in a lot of these videos that we
make
we can usually try to find a way to make
it work right you can usually find a way
and say okay so we can throw this
character in there we can we can say
okay yes they're really powerful but
like if these telepaths come together
they can do this
or if we get enough reality warpers they
can do that no there's no winning here
right there's no conceivable means
for anybody in the marvel cinematic
universe aside from like the one above
all to stop these guys
because you're talking about beings that
that killed everybody
in marvel comics right like that was the
craziest thing right those guys who
didn't who didn't read it
and if i end up remastering it a little
bit of spoiler for like a four or five
year old story but basically like when
the incursions start
uh reid richards secretly sent hank pym
into the multiverse to find out what was
going on right he sent ant-man into the
multiverse and said hey see if you can
figure out what's happening and ant-man
actually had to shrink down
to a small enough size where he could
actually squeeze between universes
right and and and literally like he's
just he's kind of free-floating along he
doesn't really know where he's going
he's just jumping from one universe to
the next and then he ends up getting he
ends up coming in into this universe
where like all the cosmic entities are
being killed at the same time right like
literally it's like opening a door and a
massacre's happening on the other side
right like literally
eternity and like in infinity and the
celestials and like all those you know
that version of galactus like they're
all just being eradicated
right and then like as he starts to look
around he realizes this is happening in
virtually every universe at the same
time
and it's the beyonders who are doing it
the beyonders are killing all the cosmic
entities so then like
after all these cosmic entities fall the
living tribunal shows up and it's like
okay cool
they saved right living tribunal is the
second most powerful being after the one
above all if you don't take into account
the marquee of death and like these
little one-off characters that we've
seen here and there
uh so if you consider like consistently
appearing characters it's the second
most powerful being in the entirety of
marvel comics
done right like like it's it's it goes
against the uh it goes against the
beyonders and the beyonders kill it
right they kill the living tribunal and
one piece of itself falls in every
single universe and and like i remember
reading that and it was it was just like
dude like okay like i don't like i don't
i don't know i don't know how to
interpret this right that was the
craziest thing that was the craziest
thing i remember reading after they're
reading that at the time and you guys
know what i'm talking about right when
you guys were reading it when it came
out you're probably like me like
okay so like hank pym is telling captain
america
and like black panther he's telling all
these guys this story and he's like you
guys don't understand
there's no way we can win all hope is
lost here there's no conceivable means
of defeating these guys who wiped out
cosmic entities
right like and that was the question
because in the story like you get what
is it you get like three quarters of the
way to the story and then like they're
in the middle of talking to galactus and
the celestials and they just leave like
they just leave out of nowhere and it's
like where did they go like you don't
know where they went to
earlier in the story you find the living
tribunal there and it's like what in the
heck is going on here right like why are
the cosmic entities
just disappearing because they're they
were being systematically massacred
across the entirety of the multiverse
and it was it was the craziest thing i
was reading that and i was like dude
i don't i don't i don't i can't i don't
know how to process this like my brain
cannot comprehend what's happening right
now that's why you're talking like this
this is a hopeless cause and a lot of
you guys have asked me to cover this
right like the beyonders and like too
powerful for the mcu to be honors
they're way too powerful
there's no means to win there's no one
here that could defeat the beyonders no
amount of magic from doctor strange
no use of the infinity gauntlet from
thanos if the one above all exists then
sure i guess you know that would
that could be the case but the living
tribunal couldn't do it but like there's
no one who exists in the marvel
cinematic universe that we could ever
even make up that could that you know
that we could bring in from the comics
who could pull that off right because
what you're talking about like the
marquee of death for example was
powerful enough to like you know destroy
a universe with a wave of his hand but
the beyonders could have done that with
the greatness of east they destroyed the
physical beings that represented the
entirety of the multiverse and then
wiped out the being that is in charge of
protecting the multiverse right so even
if we looked at characters like zom
who's probably the most powerful villain
of doctor strange
ever in the history of marvel comics
even more than dormammu there's still no
chance to win
if we bring in the marquee of death he
will fall if we bring in matthew malloy
he will die if we bring in mad jim
jaspers if we take franklin richards
into his adult form and use him he will
die too like everyone
would die nobody would live no one would
survive this encounter with the
beyonders the only way the only reason
why they well assuming that i end up
remastering it i won't tell you how they
how they fall like how they lose but
like i guess that option is available
right but it would
it would require us to travel across the
entirety of the multiverse and grab
one version of a character from every
single universe that exists out there
and then like
send them all against the beyonders at
the same time like i mean i guess in
that case
sure but at that point assuming like the
beyonders hadn't destroyed the
multiverse and we met them when they
first popped up
doing that would destroy the multiverse
like it would lead into secret wars like
we saw
where it's just battle world and there's
virtually nothing left like that action
would lay waste like it would literally
cause a chain reaction that would cause
all the universes to just
spontaneously combust or to be destroyed
across the whole multiverse so sure
we'd defeat the beyonders and wipe out
all creation in the process right so i
guess you know
zero sum game at that point you know but
nonetheless there's there's no too
powerful for the mcu there's no way to
make this work guys there's no
conceivable means for us to make it work
and to say well the beyonders could lose
under this circumstance and and still
survive i mean they would lose but
everything else would be destroyed in
the process there'd be no way for us to
make any character in the mcu survive
that's the power that we're talking
about here right like beings who can do
anything
they can alter reality on a on a
universal scale they can destroy cosmic
entities from uh from
the lowest ones all the way up to the
highest ones they're capable of creating
life
in any form or fashion that they see fit
right there's no limit to what these
guys can do
like like as a group they're on par i'd
say with the one above all individually
no
like not not by a mile like i doubt one
beyonder could have taken on the living
tribunal and succeeded but possibly i
mean it took three to kill it and that's
all it took
and the fight didn't even rage on all
that long right the fight went on i mean
what's how long did that fight go on for
in the comments guys those of you guys
who read it that fight went on for what
maybe like three minutes and then the
living tribunal died like it wasn't
really even that length that long of a
fight and it might i don't even know if
it was three minutes right i knew it was
a fight across the multiverse
but like like it was it was literally
them fighting across the multiverse
right so like imagine those old kung fu
movies where like they're
they the fight starts in like one room
and like over the course of like maybe
five or ten minutes it makes its way
through different rooms or something
like that that's what the fight between
the with the living tribunal was they
were literally passing through whatever
universes were left as they were
fighting and the living tribunal fell
this is the kind of power we're talking
about here just the ability to do
anything you want to on virtually any
level who's going to stand against you
right like who's going to be able to
defeat you nobody nobody could defeat
the beyonders right they are the single
most powerful beings that exist and the
entirety of the beyond verse right this
place beyond the multiverse but they're
the most the single most powerful beings
to ever exist in the history of marvel
comics
shy of the one above all maybe thanos
with the astral regulator right because
he possessed the power of the one above
all but that that depiction of the one
above all wasn't really accurate
in terms of being like an omnipotent
being right like he was it was basically
like i'm living
i'm the one above all i can do anything
i want to uh unless this story requires
me to not be able to do that and then i
can't
right like that's basically what jim
starlin did with that infinity ending
story or whatever it was but yeah no too
powerful for the mcu the beyonders way
too powerful
no one lives no one no one wins nobody
defeats these guys they invade the
marvel cinematic universe they lay waste
to everything in existence all the
superheroes die
all the villains who may have decided to
come together die and they probably wipe
out all the cosmic entities and all life
across the multiverse and then
leave they leave the place as just a
giant white empty void it's just a husk
of what used to be creation inside of a
universal space and nothing else is left
alive that's basically all it would be
it'd be the map makers from hickman's
avengers and new avengers except instead
of on a planetary scale it's on a
universal scale and everything's gone
and everything's dead so yeah feel free
to see if you can't
find a way to make them make them lose i
can't conceive of one these guys are
just omnipotent in virtually every
conceivable way with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you